hi my name is gonna and I'm from
Bangalore India my question who was the
inspiration asked ok actually I was
hesitating between science and arts and
so I was inspiring as well by hightower
painter or by scientists is so only at
the end of my university that died I had
to do shoes and thofe annalia was
inspired by some of my teachers in
physics and I decided to prepare a PhD I
was at the beginning I was hesitating
between science and arts and so I was
inspired by height painters directors of
movies as well as by scientists and
during the first year of my university I
short a movies and I was very attracted
by by having a career in as a director
and but then I was also inspired by some
of my professor in physics and finally
decide to prepare iperion physics and
during this phase ed I understood what I
was fascinating the research and
discovering new landscape in the field
of knowledge and so finally a westec to
physics from this time